thank you very much he was the prime
minister who warned that lobbying would
be the next big scandal
and now david cameron at the center of a
lobbying storm
facing big questions over the access he
gave
and the favors he asked for for months
he's avoided scrutiny today
finally some answers and an admission
this is a painful day coming back to a
place that i
love and respect so much albeit
virtually
but in these circumstances except
there's a strong argument that having a
former prime minister
engage on behalf of any commercial
interest no matter how laudable the
motives and cause
can be open to misinterpretation david
cameron started working for greensell
capital in 2018
lobbying governments and officials
around the world
a profitable enterprise i was paid a
annual amount a generous annual amount
far more than what i earned as prime
minister
and i had shares i you know was
absolutely
had a big economic investment in the
future of greenself
mr cameron insists the prospects of a
big payday did not motivate his frenzied
lobbying of government
56 whatsapp messages texts and emails
pleading for access to government loan
schemes early in the pandemic
among them this on april 3rd to top
treasury official tom scholar
again greensell have got to know and
genuinely baffled
this seems bonkers i'm now calling
chancellor gove
everyone then this to mr gove i know
you're manically busy
but do you have a moment for a word i'm
on this number
and very free and the next day to rishi
sanak
really grateful for your engagement on
this as agreed i think
one more conversations what's required
let's try and do it today or tomorrow
do you not feel that you have demeaned
yourself
and your position by what's upping your
way around whitehall on the back of a
fraudulent enterprise
i genuinely believed these were good
ideas to help small businesses
i did not believe in march or april
when i was doing this contact that there
was a risk of green seal
falling over mr cameron said it would be
a painful day
in the end it was absolutely
excruciating
a former prime minister told by mps that
his reputation
was in tatters that he had brought the
office of prime minister into disrepute
that his lobbying style was more like
stalking
and that he was motivated by personal
greed
accusations that were all rebuffed by mr
cameron
who acknowledged that there were lessons
to be learned but insisted that he had
acted
in good faith four hours of
interrogation but the questions still
come in with green seal and mr cameron
under investigation
from parliament whitehall the financial
regulator
a day mr cameron will want to forget but
this story far
from over beth rigby sky news
westminster